hello my name is veyas gabriela
levicious i teach history
and i'm fascinated by exploration in
particular how travel
and discovery changes people as we
consider the 50th anniversary
of humans setting foot on the moon back
in 1969
rather than reliving that drama moment
by moment
let's instead try to delve into three
related questions
that might illuminate for us the deepest
significance of this epic event
first what did it mean in 1969 what does
it mean now
and the most difficult speculative and
thought-expanding question of all
what will it mean in the future say a
century from now in 2119.
on july 20th 1969 when a world audience
of some 600 million
watched or listened to the progress of
the apollo 11
what was its significance certainly it
was a great leap for mankind
and for science but it also had very
earthly political significance
in fact it was very much a product of
the constantly shifting balance of power
on the earth
an extension of our geopolitics to the
moon
the great geopolitical confrontation of
the time of course
was the cold war between the united
states and the soviet union and their
respective allies
the cold war itself was global a
standoff on land
at sea in the skies under the seas
and even under the polar ice cap
traversed by submarines
and this competition extended inevitably
to space
the stakes were ultimate as each
adversary block
saw the space race as not just a matter
of prestige
but as a way to lay claim on the future
for its values
its ideology and its way of life
as the author deborah cadbury states in
her marvelous book
entitled space race the epic battle
between america and the soviet union for
dominion of space
the race to the moon became a defining
part of the struggle
for global supremacy and this was not
something hidden
not secret or merely implicit in reality
was out in the open
to get a snapshot of what the apollo 11
landing meant then
i did a precise surgical probe i went to
the digitized files of my hometown
newspaper
the knoxville tennessee news sentinel to
find what it had to say
on that memorable day that day the front
page bore the huge headline
the moon is red white and blue that's
geopolitics
nor had the geopolitical competition
only recently intruded into space
it was there from the start a key moment
came in october 4th
1957 when the soviets seemed to leap
forward in the race with the launch of
sputnik their orbiting satellite
the impact on america was catalytic the
determination to ramp up technology and
science
to not be left in the dust some called
it a technological
pearl harbor demanding an energetic
response
u.s spending on research soared
universities
expanded and i'll wager that a good
number of people listening to this
program
had their careers shaped by the
investments made as a result
but then only two years later in 1959
the soviet union touched the moon first
on september 14 1959 the soviets
deliberately crashed an
unmanned spacecraft into the moon's
surface this was the luna 2.
the designer of luna 2 was the genius
behind the soviet advance
the russian engineer sergey karaliov
his difficult life followed the
turmoil-filled trajectory of the soviet
union
under stalin back in 1938 karoliov had
been arrested by the soviet secret
police
falsely accused of belonging to a
counter-revolutionary organization
and engaging in sabotage he was
imprisoned in the brutal gulag
until he was recalled to the historic
mission of making space itself
soviet in addition to scientific
equipment and sensors on the luna 2
the 390-pound craft carried a special
cargo of geopolitical
significance these were medallions that
flew
everywhere after the ship crashed
settling onto the moon's surface
each one of them was emblazoned with a
hammer and sickle the communist symbol
of the soviet union symbolically
this was a way of claiming priority and
asserting its role
these medallions are still there today
decades after the soviet union ceased to
exist
domestically this triumph positioned the
soviet state as the champion of global
science
vanguard of the future as the soviet
leader nikita khrushchev remembered
of course we tried to derive the
greatest political advantage from the
fact that we were the first to launch
our rockets into space
we wanted to exert pressure on the
american militarists
and then to drive the point home the
soviets put the first man into space in
1961
the cosmonaut yuri gagarin and in 1963
the first woman
valentina tereshkova but u.s president
john f kennedy responded by
redefining the goal now the real prize
would be sending men to the moon
and returning them safely to the earth
with a keen sense for the power of
images
kennedy charted a new course the
consequences of this are discussed in
another book
i really want to urgently recommend to
you by the brilliant diplomatic
historian
walter mcdougall his book is entitled
the heavens and the earth
a political history of the space age and
it won the 1986 pulitzer prize for
history
as mcdougall points out the apollo
program was at the time
the greatest open-ended peacetime
commitment
by congress in history he argues that
american society as a whole was reshaped
as a result
entering a new realm of technocracy and
this was true
not only in regard to the space race but
in all dimensions of national policy
mcdougall puts it this way the american
administrations of kennedy and johnson
employed
induced technological revolution
followed hard by government control of
research
education economic fine-tuning and
social welfare
in all its manifestations foreign
political
and domestic social challenges it was
believed were equally susceptible to the
technological and managerial fix
qualitative problems solved with
quantitative methods
with vast prestige at stake kennedy set
about the task of winning the space race
with great intensity
at the white house kennedy demanded of
his advisors
is there any place we can catch them
what can we do
can we go around the moon before them
can we put a man on the moon before them
can we leapfrog them kennedy's vice
president lyndon baines johnson
stressed this point even more bluntly
one can predict with confidence that
failure to master space means being
second best in the crucial arena
of our cold war world in the eyes of the
world
first in space means first period second
in space is second in everything
not everyone agreed with this domestic
critics denounced the vast expense of
what they called
spacecraft and they coined the word
moondoggle
to sharpen their derision the
expectations
fostered by the sight of american
astronauts bestriding the moon were
vast in the same edition carrying the
news of the moon landing
in my hometown newspaper the knoxville
news sentinel
there was another article that announced
lunar colony could be next
to state the obvious that did not happen
in all
12 americans on six apollo missions
walked on the moon from 1969
to 1972 or rode about on a moon rover in
the last
missions the final mission was apollo 17
in 1972
since then no humans have left the orbit
of the earth
the soviets never managed to make their
new lunar rocket perform
and they canceled the program in 1974
historian walter macdougall notes an
irony setting that very dramatic goal
of putting astronauts on the moon and
then returning them safely
he writes encouraged congress and the
nation
to believe that apollo was the space
program
after the moon landing had been achieved
and the cold war prestige that promised
the urgency just ebbed away in the years
that followed
but what if today what does apollo 11
mean now
it takes on renewed significance with
some observers arguing that we are now
seeing a new more complex
space race with more actors new and old
in the united states a new space force
has been proposed in part as a response
to the growing threat of anti-satellite
weaponry
the united states hurries to ready new
domestic production of rocket engines
after nearly two decades of relying on
russian engines
as the american russian relationship has
grown more tense in the past years
add to this a striking new factor the
ambitions of private companies to plunge
into space flight
commercial ventures have stepped up thus
in 2012 the california company spacex
founded by elon musk for the first time
launched rockets carrying supplies to
the international space station
the chief of amazon jeff bezos founded a
rocket company in 2000
named blue origin in 2019 he unveiled
plans for a prototype lunar lander
and beyond this he envisions a future
when humans will construct
colonies as floating homes in outer
space other entrepreneurs have different
goals
sir richard branson a virgin galactic
envisioned space tourism
in the near future actually this factor
of private enterprise is not new but
rather a return to earlier precedence in
the history of discovery
in previous ages companies like the
dutch east india company
and the british east india company
sought profit through venturing out into
the world
christopher columbus had enrolled
private investors the brutal
conquistadors of latin america carved
out empires
with royal sanction but as military
entrepreneurs
so this aspect is in fact a reversion to
earlier patterns
and some experts suggest that private
companies might be very well positioned
to engage in mining of the moon or
asteroids for
rare minerals a new dynamic competitor
is china which has steadily ramped up
its space launches year by year
ahead of russia's record for 2017 second
only to the u.s
then in 2018 china exceeded all other
countries in number of rockets launched
into orbit
in 2003 china sent its first astronaut
into space becoming the third
nation to send its own into space the
china national space administration has
articulated
ambitious goals and has started to meet
them on january 3rd
2019 in a historic first it landed the
rover
u22 meaning jade rabbit 2 on the
so-called dark side of the moon
further plans include landing a rover on
mars by 2020
and astronauts on the moon by the
mid-2020s
china is setting a fast pace but experts
also observe
an asian space race unfolding in 2013
india launched a spacecraft the
mangalyaan mars orbiter mission
in 2019 its aim was to launch a lunar
lander
south korea advanced its rocket launch
tests
japan's aerospace exploration agency
chose toyota
to create the ultimate lunar rover by
2029
this is to be a huge vehicle with
pressurized cabins
solar panels to capture energy
essentially a lunar suv
the united states has its own plans for
return to the moon
these are not meant to be a repetition
of apollo 11 but instead are aimed to
gain experience
in more durably moving into and living
in this alien environment
in all this bustling activity of
different countries and private
companies
a key point is emerging this is not just
about the moon
rather moon aspirations have a lot to do
with mars aspirations
and even beyond in fact the moon is now
positioned to be a testing ground for a
variety of technologies
that will take us even further afield in
the solar system
and perhaps someday beyond we'll witness
how this all affects our time
as geopolitics steers space policy
and what of the last reckless and
totally unverifiable question
what will the future significance be say
in 2119
a century from now in history the
perspective of distance can offer
clarity
i would predict that in the centuries to
come that first step onto the moon
will be remembered even more than now as
an
irreducible marker of human achievement
with the passing
of time the particular details and
personalities of the cold war
will likely fade in collective memory
but the milestone
of entering a new environment will
become more prominent in our shared
human psychology i think the
psychological impact to our world view
is most significant
in fact stepping onto another sphere
actually moves us from
a world view to a world's view in the
plural
in his political history of the space
age walter mcdougall
asserted that the only proper precedent
for the human move into space
was the emergence 360 million years ago
of a creature during the devonian age
this was an ancient fish
that used its strong fins as legs moving
from the primordial seas
to begin to slowly walk across the land
an entirely
new environment what remains to be seen
is whether that milestone of the moon
landing will be a standing reproach to
humans
who did not move beyond the earth ever
again or whether perhaps
a century from now crowds of moonborne
humans
will gather at the spot where apollo 11
touched down
to mark this as a beginning of bolder
ventures that still continue
i personally think the latter scenario
is likelier
as i argue in my own series of lectures
on the history of explorers for the
great courses
in human history epic journeys have
provoked
more journeys so it actually would be a
break with long-standing precedent
for the human race to stay home
obviously the technologies that might
allow
humans to move much farther to other
planetary systems
are only being imagined at present
finally
one other thing is likely to be the case
just as geopolitics helped to define the
meaning of apollo 11
in 1969 and continues to play a role now
the odds are good that these very human
patterns of politics
will have an effect in 2119 as well
unless there are still greater surprises
in store for better or worse
history after all is itself a realm of
[Music]
surprises
[Music]
you